[Music]
first of all it's my honor and pleasure
to be presenting along with Adam from
maybe in Bev Thank You Manju it's a
pleasure to be here and very happy to be
on stage with you and Pluto seven and
part of this whole GCP operation thank
you
so a little bit of background anyway the
slides will be distributed so I'm
founder CEO of Pluto 7 we are one of the
key partners for machine learning and AI
implementation at Google so we work with
customers like a B in Bell when they
when they raise innovation challenges
right when they say okay we want to see
what machine learning and AI does for
the industry is it relevant for us if it
does but all the domain expertise that
we bring in personally I've been doing
17 years of predictive analytics work
and solving for many large enterprises
starting my career at Cisco and then
went on to solve for 30 different
companies now with the power of machine
learning and AI it really opens up our
our minds in terms of what's possible
like we have heard in many different
sessions including the keynote today
this is the next big wave that we are
going to go to which we are going to
embark on now with that said what we
want to show you is a real example of
something that matters to all the beer
drinkers in this room the taste of the
beer so we're going to talk about how we
improved we the taste of the beer and of
course dollar savings ROI and so on what
machine learning idea so I like Adam to
quickly introduce himself and then we'll
get started
Adam do you want to give a little bit of
background about you and Abyan well sure
so my name is Adam spun Berg I'm
actually in my first year at a B and Bev
but already have had a chance to work
with some great partners like Pluto
seven and manju I'm leading the digital
transformation of the company on the
supply side our team is called tech
supply and what we're trying to do is
find cutting edge
opportunities to transform to what we
call the brewery of the future and that
is a world where perhaps predictive
maintenance artificial intelligence
machine learning all of these aspects
are incorporated into the automation so
that we're functioning on a higher level
and doing things that quite frankly
weren't even imaginable a few years ago
right so we have a lot of products at a
B InBev here are some examples
Budweiser I think you've all heard of
that
Bud Light as well of course Stella
Artois we have some of here
Corona technically its constellation has
Corona in the US but we have the rest
and all of that is brewed in Mexico in
our breweries and we're the number one
beverage company in the world and
actually the number one consumer
products company in the world by some
metric anyway so sure so we have
obviously a huge operation it's a truly
global company and that's something that
really excited me about the opportunity
when I jumped onboard the fact that
there really is a presence in every
continent
well not Antarctica I should say but
everywhere else if someone can find a
way to use technology to make brewing
possible in Antarctica maybe we would
get that too but we have we have all the
continents we have nine zones and that
presents a lot of extraordinary
opportunities but also challenges with
the demographics and you know one area
that can speak a common language I guess
you could say is innovation and
technology and that's why you know one
of my plans and working with Pluto seven
and Google is to find opportunities for
using that to create that common thread
and create a global operation instead of
a fragmented this zones doing this that
zone is doing that so machine learning
is actually it's not just a cool pilot
or an interesting you know cost-saving
initiative or beer tasting improvement
it's actually a mechanism or vehicle
for bringing about more cohesion within
the organization and that's pretty
exciting Thank You Adam now a lot of the
elements of innovation involves going
back to some fundamental aspects of how
you be humans behave now I'll set the
context we'll go through a use case a
very quick demo and so that you can
relate how machine learning in the eye
is applied in a real-world use case like
in this case in putting the taste of
beer with filter replacement and so on
the last few minutes we'll have a Q&A
session and we will have some of the my
team members who are around sitting in
the front as well as some Googlers to
help out if there any specific questions
that we are not able to answer in the
larger setting so a few things to think
about why is machine learning and AI a
big deal now right it's been around for
30 years
used by space defense and all kinds of
security industries and so on but what's
the inflection point the inflection
point really is a combination of cloud
computing mobile the press the cost of
processing going down which means you
can run a lot more mathematical
computation now to make simple decisions
the decisions could be around a
classification problem you're trying to
classify whether the filter is good or
bad which is an example we look at our
regression which is what I did for 17
years you know what's the demand
forecast for the next 12 months 24
months and so on and we used all kinds
of statistical models and got an
accuracy of 70% now when we we went into
one of these companies and when they
when we said hey we are gonna beat your
whatever the best model you have three a
statistical statistical model softwares
and so on they're like we have been
doing this for twenty years there's no
way you'll come in for six weeks and be
done to cut the long story short we made
it by 20% and it was a bit shocking and
disturbing to them that we challenged
some of their best demand planners right
now the point I'm trying to make here is
this is a paradigm shift and the why is
the power
shift is because we are taking something
very fundamental to us and allowing a
machine to do that which is decision
making if you look at an enterprise look
at whether its invoice processing to
supply or ring to demand planning to
replacing apart maintenance there are
dismal decisions made at every stage
many decisions made by a human some
decisions are very expensive if you may
if you make a bad decision it can cost a
lot of a lot of money as well as a lot
of disruption now you're taking that
very simple decision making and making
that into a machine learning model which
will host in GCP which is a very quick
demo I'll worship show you as well so in
this journey when we take whether it's
filter replacement of forecasting if you
leave it up to humans and by the way
this is by no means to say that we will
replace humans it's it's to augment
humans to make improve the accuracy
level to help to make better decisions
to do the filter replacement a watch
filter replacement not waking up and
checking the filters and the beer
quality every time but letting the
Machine do that day in and day out 24 by
7 so leaving up to humans there is in
these decision-making there is bias
involved we call it experience right to
some extent but by the time we gain
decades of experience as a bias and what
data columns are important what's not
important we ignore some of the signals
in the data patterns on the columns we
ignored like in some of the large
enterprises we looked at 200 columns of
data humans wouldn't practically have
time and energy and capacity to scan
through that every hour 24 by 7 and look
at patterns across this 200 columns
continuously being generated so that's
where machine learning plays a role and
some of the slides that I'm going to
share before we go into the brewing
example is to have you understand that
the conversations that we are having and
the experimentation and innovation
that's happening
is is not just about predictive
maintenance but in the whole supply
chain ecosystem we get involved with how
machine learning and AI can help beating
demand forecasts in this case the
example I give for enterprise bidding
where 20% or reducing supply inventory
carrying cost by 50% it's a publicly
posted case study on Google cloud on how
we improved care for our Amazon seller
by 50% their invented carrying cost went
down by 50% so similarly like can the
deliveries be improved can you what
opportunities did I miss because I did
not understand my customer better when I
say customer engagement customer
experience management it's seen as a
marketing and a sales problem but you
are selling a product and in the
Detailers or online retailers world the
customers are looking at on a website
looking at your email campaigning
placing an order you do not want to run
in an all-stock situation or even if you
have stopped you do not want price to be
the factor where the customer doesn't
buy or you do not want to be a quality
issue which is a factor which is
reflected in the customer comment
sentiments and so on so these are
various variety of problems that we are
solving for customers now when it comes
to preventive maintenance and so on so
whether it's tracking inventory
defective inventory or logistics or
equipment failing these are all
different scenarios that where humans
are applying their their decision making
again there are certain decisions which
are simple or or it can be you can call
we can make it a component as in this
particular decision I can build an ml
model and this one I cannot and
realizing that is a very key element in
this innovation exercise so Adam would
you like to add anything around the
various use cases that you guys are
thinking in Abyan Bev where do you think
machine learning may help or already is
helping sure and you know part of that
digital transformation
was speaking to before we're trying to
define ways to automate the breweries
but in a smart way you know it's not
just enough to we're not trying to
replace people with technology we're
trying to find technology that as Manju
alluded to improves quality reduces
costs and just makes us more efficient
in general as an operation and you know
for for example take something like
predictive maintenance you know which
we're alluding to here say you have a
machine that if you're able to predict
an equipment failure or an equipment
problem say something aware and tear in
advance and you replace that equipment
faster you might prevent a shutdown that
stalls production or produces a lower
quality product at that time and a way
beyond what a human being is capable of
doing so in essence it's a big challenge
for us but as the technology keeps
improving you get this influx of
exciting opportunities and you know our
attitude is we want to work with these
cutting-edge possibilities and just keep
exploring and seeing what we can figure
out testing pilots proof of concepts and
you know hopefully if something really
sticks and shows promise to then expand
that into a business-as-usual
type of possibility and when you think
of businesses like a bee in Bev and to
me it was a bit overwhelming when they
showed up and I'm gonna be showed up at
the plant to take a visit the plant I
have some of my colleagues here walk
through the production floor believe
they make like hundred thousand barrels
a month now think about a production
downtime impact you're trying to replace
a filter and you have to bring down a
line think about the trucks that is
coming and things about the packaging
and the human resource the labor
customer impact distribution impact so
something as simple as one part
replacement can disrupt the whole supply
chain so when when companies when I say
be in there were similar large
enterprises when they look at automation
looking and talking to Google and
fortunately I have been involved with
many of these fact
automation of global companies who are
distributed around the world with the
c-level executives they think about all
the way the entire factory automation
all the way from the time our raw
material is brought into the door to our
time of finished goods leaves the door
right what all can automate using
machine learning ai IOT sensors and the
fact that we are collecting all the data
on the cloud now what can i aughtta mate
like because now the expectation of
delivery lead time is reducing
expectation of down times reduction is
is is increasing so there's a lot of
these things happening at the same time
because the c-level executives a CTO as
the CIOs are realizing now this is a
power that they need to harness so a
being bear through their incubator
program that that Adam just mentioned
has been thinking about it for more than
a year year and a half and these are
companies there are like many many
decades old and to for them to be
looking at these cloud and machine
learning and saying where can i
implement machine learning and AI do to
improve my overall manufacturing
experience and so on is is something
that whether it's a be in there are
similar large companies we are looking
at where we plug in which component you
know can i improve the safety of
manufacturing can we decrease the
production downtime can we improve the
quality of the product right so some of
you are there in the keynotes today
keynote today by and we're faithfully i
believe she presented on auto ml and and
it's pretty fascinating a we're working
with few customers on some pretty
innovative use cases right so auto ml is
like a hybrid where you you you you
don't really need to get into the depth
of machine learning model yet with your
data set you can get prediction results
then there are two extremes to the left
and right pre-built ml models which are
vision API translation api these are
machine learning models at Google
continuously training all you need to
pass is an input and get a result then
on the right side is the custom ML model
which is what I'm going to demo which is
more sophisticated which gives you a lot
of flexibility but you have to build
your own machine learning model so in
when you look at this process you don't
want to look at it as well can I use
this fancy or shiny object called
machine learning I which is what many
customers sometimes start off to think
that okay there's something cool I can
use this and so on because at the end of
the day if you don't really tie to the
use case if you don't tie to the kpi's
and if you don't convince somebody like
Adam this project doesn't go too far
right and and he has to in turn align
with the stakeholders and so on so you
have to relate to the business and how
you're going to transform twenty
twenty-five years back if somebody said
you know Internet would change many
aspects of your business and every
department it would have been hard for
many people to comprehend right we are
dealing with the same thing or and to
some some leaders claim and which I
believe it's too if this is going to be
a bigger revelation than Internet era
why because we are giving our
decision-making aspect and taking help
of a machine that's that's quite hard
for humans to do but once you do that
and you know that you know it's
incredibly powerful now we get to the
next level with that we're going to
obviously talk about the brewing a
example what we did and so on so I spoke
to you about few other examples so now
the customers are looking at it from a
360 degree angle right what can I do for
my dev you know preventive maintenance I
demand my supply now if I can control my
demand and supply can also adjust my
price think about an online retailer
right who has to make decisions on price
points every hour or every few hours
based on stock based on demand and so on
so for them pricing is not a separate
department Marketing is not a separate
department and supply demand planning is
not a separate department even if they
exist separately my department they work
in a circular
harmonious way so with that now the
customers are looking at can can you
automate different machineries devise
x-ray machines can you tell me ahead of
time when the machine will go down
that's the most important thing if you
if you tell right when it fails or just
a day before before it fails maybe it's
useful but if we can predict a month or
two months in advance they can line up
servicing folks to show up at the at the
factory they can have downtime planned
during a Sunday morning where nobody is
working so these are things that we are
looking at you know how do you take
existing data in the ERP s or wherever
and apply GCP machine learning and
reduce the risk level improve fault
detection and and have a more accurate
replacement dates and so on so going a
little deeper into the the beer beer
exercise itself it all started with what
can we do with machine learning and AI
right so this is our business and then
these are you know figure out what you
can do so we had an option to pick 16
different ideas we picked filter
replacement why because it had a lot of
data with machine learning if you have
not heard of this before without data
you don't have a machine learning model
right and without enough data I mean
number one number two is you have to
bring in a little bit of your innovation
thinking hat because there's a bit of
paradigm shift in designing these models
right and also you have to think about
how do you harness information what you
have not harnessed before data exists in
many forms and we'll talk about that in
a minute
so when we talk about this filtering
filtering filter replacement use case we
validated that we have a lot of data and
we lower understood the business process
behind it right if you replace this
filter
what's the business benefit how much
does it save what's the business impact
and so on so the business rationale to
do this was was was justifiable now
beyond that not only were we gonna save
money but we were saving or aamir we had
a chance to improve the taste of the
beer and with that started this whole
journey of figuring out what what can we
harness with data and that lots of data
when I say lots of data in there and
their ERP it's almost like 200 columns
of many different aspects of the the
whole brewing and production process now
we have to look at all these different
sets of columns of data think of it as a
massive Excel spreadsheet for the sake
of simplicity massive amount of
information coming in continuously and
brewmaster relies on few columns because
that's what he has relied for a long
time for decades and for the most part
he's been right and now we have all this
data and we have to improve the accuracy
level so when we looked at before we
actually rolled out the model the
accuracy level was at 60 to 70% of the
best this is a brewmaster
looking at the beer as it comes out of
the kettle passes through the filter and
and checking certain gauges and then
also looking at the beer quality itself
right they are the particles in the beer
and and there are terms like turbidity
and so on so he gauges that and it
determines whether the beer is good or
not good now you have to the model has
to tell when the Marvin when the filter
has gone wrong not too early not too
late so now we got to a 92% accuracy
level now this is something that has
been not attempted before or not thought
were nor was thought possible so what
was even more brilliant was the fact
that the brew master was very involved
with building this out and he
acknowledged that it's hard for humans
to beat this right and we were quite
amazed that you know somebody as
experienced as that and he's ready to go
through
transformation and the change so Adam do
you want to add anything to it as we
progress sure and you know the thing I
find interesting is you know it's we're
trying to improve the quality of the
tasting of the beer but I find that the
the more beers you drink the better
machine learning and AI seems to taste
as well so kind of a compelling
counterpoint no but but but here's what
I'll say is that I think a lot of people
don't know this about brewing and I
myself actually didn't know this until I
you know really got into the fabric of
a/b and bev brewing is a really
difficult long process it's it's not
like you just create some concoction
pour it in a can and lock it up you know
it's there's in some cases depending on
you know what what the brand is can be a
month-long fermentation process it's a
really almost an art form and so you
know to make an analogy of what you were
saying the brew master you obviously you
still need that human component but it's
sort of like in chess when the computers
finally started beating humans at some
point no matter how talented you are you
just can't quite be at that level that a
computer can be and so you know we as a
company can either shy away from that or
try to find a way to embrace that in a
way that keeps us competitive and you
know trying to have that marketing
position that we have within the world
so it's you know if we're not interested
in these things and not exploring what I
think is unmistakeably the future and
and it's not just beer you know this is
we're using this as our case study but
this could be anything I mean I think
even beyond the level that we can even
comprehend right now this is just the
beginning
so I don't know if I'm convinced
personally that it would be a bigger
revolution than the internet but I also
think that you know a hundred years from
now we might be bowing to robots so who
knows it's really hard too far to
predict but I think at this stage this
is responsible AI this is safe this is
controlled settings in which you're
using technology to improve
production in a way that helps business
and also you know we hope gives you a
chance to take that gulp of Budweiser
and say the aftertaste was just a little
bit better than last week yeah that's
what we're going for anyway yeah like we
are talking about you know the filter
replacement itself so it's it's about
looking at these kettles looking at the
filters and and instead of a human
judging when to replace the filter it is
using the data data to say the the
patterns of this 200 all columns and you
do feature engineering and get to
selecting 15 or 20 columns which are
data scientists do to say okay these are
20 which seems to be relevant now again
keep in mind these data scientists are
not experts in brewing business we have
a separate domain experts who understand
supply chain and all and so on and we
have customer work with us through this
innovation and we say hey we see a data
pattern which indicates that the filter
is going wrong does it seems to make
sense and the brew master and an experts
at a bean we say oh yeah that seems to
be more accurate than how we do it so
that's kind of how you go through
iteratively and and when you do this
what's important is is as the beer
quality degrades right it's it's not a
very definite of time when the beer goes
bad and it kind of gradually goes bad
and when and and ideally you want to get
to a point where you know that you know
it is now crossed that line where it
doesn't meet quality control and this
because it's it's it's a drink and and
there's subjectivity to taste and
clarity and a few other factors of
quality control you have to kind of pick
it at the right time you pick it too
slow or too late then you have let go
you know you rolled out a whole bunch of
lower quality beer or if you do it too
too late you have not only we replace
the filter sorry if you replace it too
early you're not only wasted a whole
bunch of good beer but also you increase
the cost of filter replacement more
filter replacements
so getting it right at the right time
was the most important thing and from
here moving away from 60% accuracy to
and avoiding the situation where there
is 40% inaccuracy when I say
inaccuracies and you replace the filter
when you should have not or you did not
replace the filter when you should have
so and a lot of the inaccuracies was
because of the fact and this happens in
many enterprises in many different ways
in other use cases as well
because of our experience we think
certain attributes are most relevant it
could be clarity of beer it could be
temperature pressure it could be
something right basically if I am the
brew master if I relied on this I'm
going to look for these data and
whenever it takes seeds beer looks a
certain color then I'm going to decide
that the filter is ready to be replaced
and I do that but there are a lot of
data which don't have very obvious
signals or signs which it's hard for us
to apply that because when you have
current data continuously getting
updated and 200 columns and so on it's
kind of hard for us to look and see the
significance of this other data this is
where when you apply machine learning
model you're now looking at not only
data what you always looked at but also
data which which you thought was less
significant this is where our data
scientists go ahead to feature
engineering and we look at all the
columns and say these additional columns
seem to be significant because when the
data arrives at this pattern then it's
indicating that the machine learning
then it's indicating that it's time to
replace the filter so with that now what
you're really doing is you're
understanding your process you're
understanding the parameters of data
that you captured and built a machine
learning model before I go into the
model itself Adam do you want to add
anything no I I would just say you know
kind of to echo what you were saying
non-jew you know there's there really is
a precise art to this you know and it's
it's to give a really simple example
no if you all remember though those
games that we had when I was a kid were
you try to roll a ball and it would go
there'd be two humps and if you pushed
it too hard it would go over the second
hump if it wasn't didn't push it far
enough it didn't make it you're trying
to find that sweet spot in the middle
and you know because you have to err on
the side of caution this is after all a
consumer product that people are
drinking we're never going to release
something into the marketplace that's
not up to standard we're gonna err on
the side of being more careful what this
allows us to do is to know with
certainty or with almost near certainty
and we'll keep perfecting that model
that no we can wait to replace that
filter at this point or in the
alternative scenario replace that filter
right now
because we're gonna have to throw out
some beer that's not going to pass
muster so it really is a tremendous
value that this is bringing to us and
you know we'll see how it impacts things
as we keep working with with Pluto 7 but
we have really high hopes and optimism
for how this is going to affect our
business and our quality so what does
the underlying architecture itself look
like it's pretty simple and if you're
familiar with GCP if you are already
using you like to recognize some of
these logos so your ERP the data comes
from data flow which is for traditional
analytics architecture is the equivalent
of your ETL but it's more with more
power and scalability and order scaling
and so on the data we brought that into
bigquery and and we built a custom ml
model on GC ml and when I say customer
model remember the three ml models I
said you know one what you saw this
morning was out I am out the one in
between the one on the left has
predetermined more pre-built model by
Google well you don't build or train and
the one on the right is the customer
model right well for the small section
of the audience if in case you know
you're relatively new to machine
learning model you kind of want to use
machine learning model I use this and
even over on customer workshops as you
kind of think as you just hired an
intern and and you need to train the
intern on a job then you check whether
the intern is doing well and then you
put them in real job it is the same
process that you go with machine
learning right you you kind of build a
model you train the model you give the
data and see whether the the model
learnt it and then you you you once you
have confidence that the model has
learned it then you deploy the model and
and get it operationalizing
operationalize it so we are kind of
mimicking the same process here and the
model continues to learn based on the
you know how you define it and so on so
I'll kind of quickly go into GCP console
just to show you what it means to build
a model and/or deploy a model and so on
well we won't run the model itself you
know it's a it's something that you have
to kind of think that okay for this
scenario where we understood this
process of data coming in we understood
that okay it's a classification problem
of saying beer filter is good or bad
based on the data pattern and and we do
this and we train the models so that
it's making good decisions and training
the model is based on history or the
last X months or X years when how filter
replacement happen whenever those filter
replacement happened what was the data
what was the pattern of the data at that
point in time and the model is is
continuously learning from that the more
data and the more training there is it's
better but you know it doesn't mean you
continuously keep training there's an
optimal point up to which you want to
train to get to your level of accuracy
and so on so with that so let me quickly
go into GCP console so when during this
whole exercise of understanding the
business process understanding the use
case then we understand the data and
from there we build a model the model
once it's built its is deployed in
Google cloud so this if you go under
this is GCP console in case anybody's
new so we would go and build the model
and we'll deploy the model here so the
model itself is at the core of it you
want to think of it as a mathematical
function that has been data mined right
based on your data pattern it's a
mathematical function and that's hosted
on a tensor flow so now we leverage the
tensor flow framework and and then you
have deployed the model the version 1
and as you and this is a dummy model we
for confidentiality reason we can't show
you the actual model and so on so you
can you can put the model to run
repeatedly and you know every day or
however often you want the model to run
and train the model to train the model
so you use carry you have the model
that's running and then you have a
training job right so essentially you
build the model you deploy the model on
the cloud and you train the model and
behind the scene so behind the scene
when I said feature engineering what and
the column selections and so on what is
a combination of applying your domain
knowledge and a combination of applying
data sciences and understanding some of
the practicalities of how your model
itself the what you want the models to
do so based on all those things you
select your columns or features that's
what we have it in the left you know
this is part of the model code and then
on the right is which deep learning
model do you want to apply based on
based on your use case if it's a
regression is in this case is a
classification and which model works
best and there are different factors
that goes into into which model to
select there was a session earlier today
by Prashant Inga he's probably around in
the audience so he's over there and you
can always ask him more about you know
which model to select as his is from
Google and there's a lot of experience
in not only determining which which is
the right model for the data scenario
the business scenario and and the kind
of data that you have it also comes with
lot of a
experience that Google brings them by
solving in not only internal Google's
own problems
Intel operational problems where the
machine learning has been applied if if
there are thousands or ten tens of
thousands of machine learning model
Google internally uses to run their own
business along with that the industry
experience solving for some of the
largest companies today you saw target
in the keynote right so there are many
many companies Google is continuously
solving all those learnings are going
into these deep learning models in under
the using tensorflow and when you use
some of these models recommended by
Google there is a lot of intelligence
going behind it as well so that some of
the feature engineering and all those
burden that you put on a on a person
building on machine learning models
those are that those intelligence are
part of it as well so there are various
sessions at Google next which goes
deeper into these models and also during
Q&A if there are a few things that we
can answer we'll do that as well
the one of the common question that I
get asked when we're running workshops
and proof of concepts and production
rollouts is a very early on people ask
which bottle is the best model for what
I want to solve right so we have to kind
of take them few steps back do you even
need a machine learning model let's
figure that out first right of the time
people don't need machine learning model
they think they need a machine learning
model they don't need it the second
thing is okay even if you need a machine
learning model do you have enough data
the right kind of data or even if the
data is that for ready for you to
prepare the data the whole ROI for that
is not justified and so let's go through
some of these basics Google strictly
follows these disciplines that when you
don't need an fact when when I first
attended a Google machine learning
training if you don't need a machine
learning model don't build one because
you're gonna just spend money and
realize that there are better ways to do
it
part when you realize that you have a
right use case and right data set the
power of machine learning will be
obvious by itself so taking this a
little forward we the whole exercise was
done in like six weeks right and take
the accuracy from 60% to close to 92%
accuracy and and based on the region and
zone doing million dollar savings and so
on now it's one experiment done in one
part of a B InBev now like this there
are about 15 our experiments are 20 or
experiment Sabian Bev is considering
it's not so much justice significance of
what came out of this project it's it's
rethinking how you run your business now
looking at your manufacturing floor and
saying what else can I do with this
right now that I'm on GCP I'm on the
cloud and I understand how machine
learning model can be built making human
decision making so again it's not about
replacing humans it's about augmenting
humans we are not going to replace every
human decision-making capability into an
ml model it doesn't work that way human
brain is incredibly complex you can't
make every decision making and those
decisions are not like you cannot
combine that into one one holistic set
there are many small decisions humans
make and there's an overarching decision
that's made which kind of works in
coordination so beyond building models
like this it's also getting stakeholder
alignment and realizing that you need
more data these are critical things that
become obvious to our customers as we
build us these models you're not
anything Adam yeah I do so you know the
stakeholder alignment this is
interesting question and obviously not
every company has the same view of
innovation and within a company you know
there are all kinds of apples so the
important thing and you know I'll be
honest this is something that I've
learned is just incredibly valuable in
navigating any kind of big corporate
culture is you have to get buy-in from
the right people early on because if you
start working on something and it's very
exciting maybe to the local team maybe
the brewmaster is really into it maybe
people on site and even people in the
innovation program but if you don't have
those hire stakeholders really
supporting this you're going to run into
obstacles along
way and the way to overcome that is you
have to make that case early and you
have to make sure what you're doing gets
visibility and is understood and I think
you know this is a challenge for all of
us to some people machine learning is a
scary concept or something that's just
beyond their realm of interest right now
and you can't force that but you have to
find a way to slowly bring about that
understanding and evolution so that's
where you know I think it's really
effective when you can work
collaboratively and this is where Manju
and I have really found some common
ground is we both saw the value in this
project obviously from two different
sides but really we were a team on this
we said okay how what can we do to make
this compelling to the right people and
you know we're still we're still winning
some people over but we got enough
people on board to really understand
this so for those of you out there in
companies that are looking to you know
pursue this track you know I would say
definitely think about that aspect
because the impulse is just go how
exciting just run with this but you have
to think bigger picture if you really
want to implement an impactful change
that goes beyond the local aspect one
key element I would like to highlight is
ml is a journey it start off with the
project you'll comprehend first you know
why this is powerful and so on in a
business context for a use case then
then it's it's an effort to kind of
bring everybody else along with you in
the journey and you have to assume that
some some portion of the organization
will not align with this for various
interests but either they just don't
want to deal with the new technology or
it appears too complex it's not reliable
whatever the reasons are there is a
certain amount of awareness education
and some folks don't want to go with it
so you have to realize what battles you
are picking and keep progressing and
realize that this is a journey you are
in it your competitors are in it the
whole ecosystem is in it so just to
summarize from a prediction quality
standpoint with a 92% accurate
see taking about six months of data and
getting to the right amount of right
kind of values to get to and where the
right kind of values so that the
business has the confidence that yes if
we do this there is this certain amount
of money that's getting saved not only
money getting saved there is improvement
in our production improvement reduction
in our production downtime and so on so
I had to go in and present to the
c-level executives on how it was done
and and why there was so much of
difference in how it is manual versus
machine learning model and so on so it's
pretty impressive too for I believe year
100 plus year old company yeah I mean
the first the first brewery in
anheuser-busch anyway were in st. Louis
and obviously there's been mergers and
acquisitions and all kinds of stuff
since then but you know this isn't in
the technology or a product that was
invented yesterday but you know it keeps
evolving with time just like anything
else and one of the executives messaging
that they want to make it to AI based
brewery I mean that's pretty amazing
so in summary there's a filter
replacement problem and the outcomes we
just discussed which is replacing the
filter at the right time driving
millions of savings by region zone
[Music]